alright guys bangbang I have Dan here
with me super excited to do this dan and
I have known each other for a little
while now and he may be one of the most
important people on the Internet
can I say that I think so where the
what's going on man
so this working away absolutely all
right let's uh let's go to your
background first and we can get into all
the different things that you've got
going on but you start with your
background yeah quick background in high
school I had trademarked the catchphrase
who's your daddy from a three hundred
products and I license it out for nine
point five million dollars when I was 19
years old twenty three years old took in
public I'm stock market the next five
years I don't really remember I got us
into fifty five thousand retail stores
in America just didn't sleep for half a
decade after that I want to know the
feather in my cap so I start an online
poker site and put on the backpack I
moved to maltose started a poker site
within ten months with a third biggest
poker brand in the world
so I signed dan Bilzerian DJ Steve Aoki
all these different characters to help
build the brand and then boom online
poker shut down in America it's called
Black Friday and so I had to figure out
what the heck do I do so I became an
angel master and my angel messin 36
company since then and I started a
social media agency and the social media
agency is my day job that's my main
focus last year we spent sixty million
dollars with influencers for products
brands and mobile apps and then my main
core passion is my charity where we make
backpacks for the homeless with 150
items inside so like I told everyone at
the beginning you've done ton of [ __ ]
your have touched a lot of different
aspects of the internet let's go all the
way back to Hoosier daddy where did that
idea come from so my friend in high
school he kept saying it and people kept
laughing about it or they thought it was
like quirky or interesting or sexual or
sports there was different meanings to
it so I just decided to put t-shirts I
just decided to make some t-shirt and my
older brothers I go you should trademark
that but you probably won't be able to
because it's such a big name it was
already a music songs already like a
thing well I wouldn't lift it up and the
trademarks are available so my attorney
filed trademarks all over the world we
spent like 20 grand which we didn't
really have
and we trademarked it and then we went
to a clothing convention we wrote over a
million dollars and orders at the
convention and we were right next to
Daymond John FUBU started the same year
right next of Daymond John and Sean John
cuz did he started the same year also I
was like I didn't know how big they were
gonna be back then right and so we
realized we were on to something and so
we went in found a clothing manufacturer
got screw and made money got scooter
went through all that stuff and then got
a nine point five million dollar
licensing deal with starter apparel and
that kind of helped us through the
roller coasters and making money losing
money as kids and the clothing was our
main focus until the energy drink that
became the huge focus so yeah
forty-three distributors 55,000 stores
at what point did you realize like hey
the clothing store or the clothing line
is doing well and obviously we've got
kind of multiple millions of dollars
there but the energy drink could be
bigger and that's where we should go
focus on so I saw a void in the market
there was 900 energy drinks and they all
they'll taste like cough syrup nobody
enjoyed it and I looked at the cooler
and it was all black cans and silver
cans and so I just noticed that they
were all a replica of Red Bull but
nobody can touch red because they were
multi millions and sales so I was like
what if I don't make the biggest energy
drink I just make the best-tasting one
and so I went on a hunt to find this
chemist that mean fruity flavors like
Gatorade I found this guy and we
licensed the original formula which was
cranberry pineapple and he said if you
do a million dollars in sales I have
another one which is a green tea okay
great so we did a million sales in like
seven weeks I like seriously just didn't
sleep I just banged on every door once
every liquor store which every
distributor and then we got the Green
Team we won back-to-back flavor of the
year that was the most important because
on bed net they have 900 drinks to
choose from when we won that it was over
I went to every retailer I was like look
this is us this is us hey we're already
in 7-eleven we're in Costco and I don't
really remember and of all those stores
I met with ever pitching like I never
asked for a sale
I was just helping them fill out an
order form I think I was explaining that
they have to carry us because of this
and so I think that I don't know if it's
cockiness or strength or passion
whatever you want to call it I see
really don't remember not being able to
sell it and during that time the
clothing kept selling but it was kind of
an afterthought because it would do a
couple million bucks in revenue and the
licensee ones were doing good overseas
but the energy drink had the massive
explosion yeah and then when you took
the company public at a 23 you were the
youngest CEO to ever take company public
right is that still the case or somebody
beating it no nobody beat yeah we beat
that Michael Dell guy by year you got me
by a couple billion but I love it and
why did you take the company public role
is the idea there yeah so there's some
bakers that came to us they were based
like if you want to launch an energy
drink you're gonna need a little war
chest to go fight with rockstar red bull
on stir and they were very right because
even when we got orders you're paying on
net 30 or next 60 terms hopefully
usually net 90 and so Costco would write
us an order for a 1.8 million sounds
great so you got to come up with 900,000
to make it ship it two months from now
and get paid a month or two later and
then get reorders in between and they
haven't paid you for the first order and
so we always needed more and more money
it was very very capital-intensive and
so i'm glad that we went it was a
headache being public back then this was
right when star Bay's Oxley started it
was a headache being public because most
the time you're spending 10 to 20 hours
a week with your accountants and CFOs
and going through audits and self audits
and everything but being able to get
that kind of capital I needed to be
public yeah at that time that's what I
was told
got it that make sense and then what was
the fascination on the poker side cuz I
know you still play poker do a lot of
charity poker stuff but when did that
start yeah so my family always played
poker
my uncle won a bunch of championships
they my aunt and uncle owned like a
small poker room in California my dad
loved it my mom like it was just in the
family and so I played a lot and I
started playing pretty high stakes in my
20s playing and I started meeting on
these big business people and
celebrities and athletes in these poker
games people who never normally get to
meet I was meeting at these high-stakes
poker games and so I started
incorporating it for charity poker
tournaments every year I started doing
charity poker with Steve Aoki every year
I was just started incorporating to
whatever business I was doing I added
poker so when the opportunity came to
start an online poker site same thing I
saw a void in the market 550 sites so a
huge competition but nobody was like the
cool one and I thought what if I go get
those Aryan a yogi Playboy Playmates
poker pros and put them all together and
make a big team and so my competitors
they were doing four million and eight
million dollars a day in revenue like
net I mean it's crazy I started I was
the little engine that could I had 2.5
million total to start a poker site and
so I leveraged their audiences they all
had big TV shows so I wouldn't started
playing on every TV show in the world
those area started playing on TV shows
Aoki started playing I was training
models how to play poker and go have
them play on high-stakes TV shows just
because they're like what the heck's is
real doing here she's never played poker
before and so we went out there that way
and I couldn't afford to outspend them
so when they made a 9 million dollar TV
show three of the nine players were my
guys wearing my company name got it I
only do the marketing yes super super
smart and really just trying to
understand where is attention right
where people focus that how do you kind
of ride that wave okay and then so once
you're doing that you come back to the
US and and you start the social media
agency what was the the kind of driver
there so I started buying posts from
different people but this is when social
media was first getting started we're
talking 2011 and 12 when it became you
know right after the myspace days now
there's some social media platforms
Twitter's just sitting around YouTube is
taking off like this is that a couple of
years where we were just like you know
we weren't all on social media but we
knew a bit right and so I started buying
posts for the post where it's completely
mispriced
Kourtney Kardashian can charge seventy
five thousand dollars for one tweet back
then right 25,000 50,000 like the
numbers were because we didn't know but
they also would send you a hundred
eighty thousand clicks to your site
because there wasn't much else to follow
right there wasn't that many people on
these platforms and so I started buying
post from influencers really really
cheap because they didn't know what to
sell it for so I'd pay them a hundred
bucks
two hundred oh I'm in most tournaments
and then when I started doing that I was
also angel nesting and so some of these
brands I would say hey take ten grand
let's go buy a bunch of posts opposed
about your health product or fitness
product & bogel or whatever and I just
saw a big arbitrage situation where as I
did that I started getting hit up by
friends and own brands that I didn't
have a piece of and they were like hey
can I give you a hundred K or fifty K to
go play with to do what you did for your
brands and so that's why I decided to
formalize an actual agency out of it and
yeah the rest was history got it and
early on like what was the conversations
like did the influencers understand how
big they would get and kind of really
realize how much value they could
provide or was it more hey I want to go
buy something at the store you know I
need ten grand let me get ten gram I
post it on social media yeah they still
don't really understand there's like
this many that actually understand what
it means to get as many eyeballs as they
do but back then actually I expect that
from 2012 to 17 really that happened
decade was the Wild West it's still kind
of Wild West like I can still find
influencers and have five million
followers then I pay the same rate as I
do people $200 because there's just
differences of niche influencers versus
mass appeal which is just a hot guy or
hot girl like there's just different
categories that an influencer has 20,000
followers that just talks about business
finance or just talks about welding or
cars a Ford would pay that person way
more than they would pay a five million
dollar a person and so I saw that back
then they had no idea but you done 12
2007 teen literally no idea and so I was
able to just make up prices and I never
to take advantage of them it was just
like hey I'll give you 500 bucks for
this post or I'll give you two grand can
you do five posts for me and I never had
them say no because they're just free
money so then they're like we don't have
much to post anyway so yeah and one of
these people why understanding is like
from those early days that have become
the influencers everyone knows and loves
today a lot of them have friends right
they they kind of grew up together if
you will understanding hey what are you
doing right how are we much are you
getting paid you know how do you get
your followers all that kind of stuff
right that's one of the biggest
questions I get is how much should I
charge still to this day but especially
for those years they just don't know
like doesn't matter
the Kardashians a fitness simple answer
of beauty influencer and didn't matter
nobody knew because there was no
forefathers of influencers like there
was no like guy in every magazine or
article that came out I've never seen
one out of the hundreds of articles I've
read never one that's even close to what
the rates actually are never not even
close can you tell us what the rates are
so it's asking same thing is like asking
how much was a car this is it a Porsche
Ferrari which Ferrari there's levels of
rice right there's a cheap Ferrari and
expensive Ferrari or rare Ferrari so
it's hard because two influencers with
the exact same followers that to both
have pomp has 1 million this Fuhrer has
1 million their rates are still
completely different you could have
almost everything the same and still
have completely different rates and not
like buy a little your rate could be 10
grand and hers is for 400 bucks it's
really weird
and so a lot of it is just understanding
what their audience is like what do they
talk about and will people care some
brands don't care about any of that
stuff they just want eyeballs like
McDonald's we're never gonna sell more
burgers it doesn't matter if you're a
Kylie Jenner nice someone perfect for
them right they won't feel it nothing
that they could feel when they sell
billions and billions of billions of
burgers right they do want more eyeballs
so they would pay actually Burger Kings
the best example Burger King used to
give me rates that were three to six
hundred percent higher than they needed
to pay and I would tell them very
bluntly like this is way too much I
don't need to pay this girl or this guy
that kind of money and they didn't care
they just wanted impressions and they
just wanted them to think about them so
I'd go to influencers that I normally
give 10 grand to and I'm gaming them 40
and I was like it hurt me because I was
like you could I can buy 4 posts for you
from the same price like no no this is
great
and so some brands are still so slow to
understand what the impressions are
worth and some just want to have as much
adoption or as much as possible yeah how
was the pricing work right so like one
of the things that really fascinates me
is kind of the difference between that
brand advertising versus the direct
response or actual conversion do you see
more people wanting to work with
influencers on the direct response side
or is it just hey I want to get my brand
out there I want to get those
impressions
sure so movie studios and music related
companies
they just want as many eyeballs as
possible because they don't care they
have a main idea of their audience but
they want everybody come to movie right
when it comes to physical products like
a 15 your sugar bear hair fashion know
those type of brands they want ROI they
want to spend a thousand bucks to do
1841 dollars in sales and whether they
break even or come close to it they're
happy because they know somebody will
reorder right if you know something will
reorder your product three four five six
times a year you're willing to break
even or even lose money knowing that
they're gonna reorder it if your product
you don't know they're gonna be order or
it's a one-time-use product like a New
York Yankees hat they might only buy
once because they'll wear that same hat
for years because they love it right
they're not gonna buy 60 Enki cents per
year so the New York Yankees would say
hey I need to spend a thousand bucks but
I need to do at least two grand or more
because otherwise it's a failure so it's
thinking about how much is a person
worth to them when we did campaigns for
draftkings and they knew a player is
worth a few hundred dollars to them so
for them they could spend five hundred
thousand they spent five thousand
dollars with me in one weekend once
here's four hundred thousand just for
the weekend don't get DJ khaled amanda
cerny all these King match you know
these characters all together at the
same time it's a post about this
promotion and it worked absolutely
amazing they were ecstatic we actually
did a whole nother campaign the
following week that wasn't planned
because it just did so well there's
other brands that say here's a hundred
grand go do this wha-wha-wha because the
main thing about social media is I can
lead millions of horses to water I can't
make them drink right your products for
us to be good like kwibi puppies getting
ripped apart in the media yeah 1.8
billion dollars in financing and they
don't even have what is like 800
thousand downloads that's insanity
like I like actual insanity and they
have household names like Kevin Hart and
JLo like huge characters that they're
just not formatting to make it feel real
and they're not making it's not a social
brand meaning if I watch could be on my
phone I can't share it it's really
strange for somebody as smart as
Katzenberg and meg whitman these are
very smart humans that have built up
huge companies it not having a social
media service
be social is freaking weird yeah it's
super super weird on the influencer side
like what are you seeing in the change
in kind of revenue streams right so
obviously early on I think a lot of
people just said wait a minute
you're gonna give me money I'll post on
my Instagram or my Twitter account that
sounds like an awesome deal I'll do that
I think now we've seen kind of a shift
though from that too
more people are watching their own
products their own brands kind of
building companies and going more that
entrepreneurship route or is that me II
just kind of misunderstanding what's
happening so influencers that have a
stable following and good following who
are growing following they should have
their own products meant to be what
can't just be another clothing line
right like we started talentless the
clothing line with Scott Disick millions
millions millions of dollars revenue
fantastic but he won't actually post it
once every week or two it's not him
posting all the time it's us running
paid media about him and to his fans
most influencers don't realize if you
start another phonecase company or
another sweater hoody company it's just
another product and at some point your
followers you've exhausted them because
if you have a million followers and you
post about your hoodies every single day
okay we get it after a week or two or
three we got it whoever's gonna buy your
hoodie would have done it already right
and so that gets capped the only time
that makes sense for them is if they're
actually gonna run paid media to go
along with it however even if it gets
capped they're gonna make more let's say
they sold 140,000 of these hoodies and
t-shirts
that's more to them than what they would
have made them paint posts and it's
easier for them to post about because
let's say they like planes if they make
goodies or sweaters with planes on them
that's more relevant to them than making
more or less or the same it's still
worth it to them and those paid posts
won't go away so they can still post for
the fashion brands they can still post
for a headphone company right
they can still do those posts and have
their brand it's critical once you have
a large medium to large fonts you do
that you have a small following it's
really tough yeah it's super interesting
too I guess because there's kind of the
traditional products that you're talking
about right just hey I've got another
hooding of the phone case etc versus
very specific like
audience fit with you know Kylie Jenner
is probably the best example with the
lip kit there's a couple of others it
seems like the more people are getting
sophisticated the more opportunity there
is but you do have to be one of the
folks with a stickier larger audience
it's not just have got 100 followers
because you can't really build a
business or a product out of that sure
and the other thing is it's becoming
easier and easier Shopify and
clickfunnels I mean it's so easy to
actually spin up a real site that's
actually built out for your audience
it's gonna convert well for you before
it was like you know clicking buttons
trying to figure out how to make a good
website Shopify and made it a really
great platform for that also white
labeling has become so easy
utilizing Alibaba and utilizing these
drop shipping companies and utilizing
white label specialists like if you want
to make a clothing brand you can just
use different companies the same way
that Jake Paul and all these characters
they use different platforms there's
four or five main ones that the
influencers all use because they'll do
same-day printing or same week printing
and so then you have to stock up a big
inventory because they can just say hey
I'm an influencer whether they sell 120
shirts that say pump on it or they sell
4000 they're not dealing with that your
palm supposed to be pop right you're the
influencer you're supposed to make the
content that you create and then have
somebody else that's a specialist go
sell your shirts for you deliver them
package them and deal with customer
service so the fact that it's gotten so
much easier to do it you're seeing more
and more that's probably why you're
seeing more and more influencers this
last year so I'm making products because
of this white labeling yeah makes a ton
of sense and then how about the
influencers work together to grow their
following try it I think a lot of folks
don't realize kind of the the
cooperation that goes on and the
realization that hey one plus one equals
four or five any scenarios yeah so
collaborations is one of the main ways
to grow followings because the algorithm
got so tough it's actually one of the
only ways to grow a rabbit like a real
true following so what happened is it
the vine stars did it best so that's why
they all lived at 1600 vine that
building back in the days that's where
they all got famous because they all
live together created content together
funny content
Fitness content Beauty content whatever
you did
you would do yourself but then you would
also collaborate with other influencers
in your field some of them did
crossovers so some of them were like hey
I'm a funny influencer you're a medium
clone sir let's make a funny beauty
video and we leverage each other's
audiences and so that happened a lot its
most critical to do when you're in a
niche if you're a fitness simple answer
a beauty influencer in the car space if
you're in the car space and you do stuff
with other people in the car space those
followings are going to interact and
want to follow you anybody following the
chef if you're a chef and the three or
four of you cook together on Sunday
nights you guys are going to gain
followings together those collaborations
are the key most critical way to grow
followings yeah and I guess really what
ends up happening is they become friends
over time right because really you see a
lot of the quote unquote
influencers all hanging out together
this is no different than if you go to
the podcast world where you've got kind
of like the intellectual dark web right
where it's a loose collection of folks
who all have podcasts that all go on
each other's podcast etc and then you
also go to even like old-school right
all the CEOs would hang out together etc
like this has happened just in multiple
forms and now it's kind of appearing on
social media if you will yes and you'll
also notice that certain celebrities are
really leveraging it so you'll see
somebody like a Kevin Hart or Steve Aoki
or the rock they'll actually go out and
interact with these influencers like
Kevin Hart and david dobrik will make
the video together Steve Aoki and
marshmallow an influencer and what's the
kid from Fortnight know they'll all
start making content together and fall
all of a sudden they go through the roof
because they're loving each other
audiences but Kevin Hart's not an
influencer from the social media sense
even though he has a huge social media
following
he's an a-list celebrity same with the
ROC same with Aoki same with marshmallow
what they'll do is they'll go get a
david dobrik or a jake paul for an
amanda cerny
and make content with them and now
everybody's happy because the
influencers they died and want to be on
TV right that is the ultimate goal even
though a TV show only has 700,000 views
and their social following post one
poster do control million views that is
the end goal getting on the big screen
whether it's TV
Netflix or
is all they care about vice versa the
rocks and the Kevin Hartz of the world
they want these influencers to post with
them to gain them more following to sell
more tickets to their shows
everybody wins but it's just like
rappers want to be NBA players and NBA
players one of the rappers the same
concept influencers one of the movie
stars but we stars want to have
influence or type engagement yeah what
why did the influencers want to get on
television or movies so badly if they
actually get less views there is it just
the legitimacy of it yeah it is like I
can't explain how passionate they are
how many castings they go to the amount
of hours and time and energy they put
they'll be in my office for sometimes
six hours reading a script to go to a
casting that they know they're not going
to get but then go through this whole
process and they'll go to 40 or 50
castings to get that one thing if ever
and when it happens even when the show
and beat comes out that's not anywhere
near as big as one post that they can do
or how much money they make from their
post that just adds to them so much
credibility and so much there's so much
passion behind it I really can't explain
it's intense like they want it so bad
yeah that's awesome
speaking of passion one of the things
that many people I think now have come
to realize that you do is you've got
this massive charity so maybe describe a
little bit about what you guys are doing
with the backpacks and kind of how that
works yeah so this is our eighth year
table model citizen fund we make
backpacks with a hundred fifty emergency
supply items inside but it's a zero
percent charity meaning I cover 100% of
cost expenses like payroll marketing
events everything not a penny ghost
anything but the backpacks and that's
how it's gonna be forever so with that
what we do is we ship to emergency
disaster situations like Porto Rico
happens first Lake in Mexico happens
we're there within a day or two like we
are able to ship right away because we
don't have the red tape but our main
day-to-day is we ship to homeless
shelters or we go out ourselves
so we'll ship to homeless shelters teen
abuse shelters and women of your
shelters that's kind of like our
mainstay mostly on the west coast and
then we'll do a bit in New York Miami
Chicago and then we'll ship to
orphanages overseas Tijuana El Salvador
etc but basically it's just a backpack
with 14 pound of supplies 150 items
half food and drinks and the other half
is like duct tape or watch books
sleeping
on show stuff like that got it and is
the thought process that the supplies
that are in there are obviously things
one the received recipient doesn't have
but two are kind of everyday items that
could be useful
essentially it yes so it's mainly some
of those things aren't even lasting a
few weeks some of them will last them
for years so it's not gonna change their
life forever
it's a more of a band-aid and then some
things in there like the sleeping bag
the backpack itself those things will
last them for longer got it and the the
events that you do to raise money are
not exactly your your grandfather's a
charity event right so maybe talk a
little bit about some of the the poker
events that you've done on the charity
side and so the other things you've done
yeah so the charity poker events are our
main thing that we like to do we do for
those a year and we like to bring in
different celebrities and actors rappers
and athletes to those because it gets
the rich friends if you will to want to
donate more because of the scene so we
create a big fun scene for them and make
it easy we're able to raise six figures
per event pretty easily because
everybody gets excited to be in the room
with these other characters and we've
done that like 30 or 40 times now we've
done those a lot four times a year for
eight years and then a couple times a
year we'll do it for somebody else so
for example Steve Aoki will throw his
charity poker tournament to help raise
money for history or we'll send a bunch
of players to Arnold Schwarzenegger's
charity well send players to other
people's charity poker tournaments just
to support them for their charities as
well and then once a year twice a year
we'll do some big blowout like we did
the world's largest pizza festival we
brought in Tyga and 2 Chainz Wiz Khalifa
and this big event for charity so we'll
do sometimes big blowout things for
charity as well and then four times a
year we do it with another charity
called Trina's kids where we'll do a
back-to-school Drive Thanksgiving food
drive report card day and a toy drive
and we'll bring a bunch of influencers
it's a lot of influencers that I name
they actually come every single time and
they'll support it we have these 400
families that bring all their kids and
so same families for last 5 years and
every every year we do those four events
a year to help those four families yeah
and it's pretty cool too because not
only are you getting the kind of a list
celebrities and the musicians and all of
them involve getting in the influencers
and then
you naturally see as you see people who
aren't influenced or celebrities also
wanted to participate some of it for the
social proof of participating some of it
because they actually care about the
cause I saw of it just because that they
think that it's something worthwhile it
makes it feel good yeah the reason I
posted on so much is I want other people
that go replicate it I don't care if
they donate to me cuz for me anybody can
go make a backpack in the city with 10
items or 3,000 items they can replicate
what I'm doing so I don't need them to
donate to me I want them to go do stuff
don't feed people or go and do a school
event and go do it back to school then
go do your own thing singing food drive
like I post about it so much I want
people to go do it I don't really
solicit funds so it's very rare I think
I've asked three times in eight years to
actually donate that was only because of
like Puerto Rico I was like hey I'll put
up a kind of I'll put up a couple on a
grant but I want to go get way more you
guys you know or the Mexico City thing
okay I'll put up a hundred grand but can
you guys do more outside of that I don't
really raise money from people for my
charity I really want them I wrote raise
awareness for charities to go replicate
it yeah super cool
speaking of awareness the various social
platforms have really changed over the
years right where are you seeing most of
the content being created and then kind
of how do you be talking right now with
with us entrepreneurs or our influencers
about building the brand and building up
their audiences sure so each one is it
has a different 911 call niche but a
different reason for it so Twitter is
like a newsfeed Twitter is where you go
you want to hear Trump yell about
something you want to find out what's
going on the financial markets you want
to see sports or you want to see things
Twitter's like that fast fix and it's
really more news oriented information
oriented Facebook is for the masses
Facebook is where you're gonna get your
best way to spread out to the masses but
mostly if you're gonna spend money
because they're restricting the reach
there so if you're spending money
Facebook is fantastic
linkedIn has become amazing because now
likes comments shares if I get eight
thousand twenty thousand twelve thousand
views on something that's worth way more
to me than twenty thousand on Instagram
obviously because that's the masses
versus all business people on LinkedIn
you know everybody on there as a job
wants a job as a career owns a company
just got fired just got hired as an
investor you know that in the business
world
there's no 13 year-olds on LinkedIn and
so LinkedIn is fantastic because they
finally made it with photos videos and
shareable YouTube is for long-form
content so you got to be a really good
creator to do YouTube you can't just do
a phone video and post on YouTube you
can but it's just not gonna have that
much traction or feel to it
YouTube is much more produced it's
really good for long-form content and
what I call evergreen content that you
can make a video now that's still
relevant four years from now or 10 years
from now so if you're in the real estate
space you make videos about short
sailing or VA loans or whatever those
things flipping a house is still
irrelevant to 10 years from now um
Instagram is the most emotional that's
the one that you want to create your
content for and then repurpose that same
video or photo on the other platforms if
you make your content for Instagram or
Facebook that'll make it easier for you
to post on Twitter Facebook etc your
Instagram video or um photo so a lot of
times people get overwhelmed when they
hear me talk about half a dozen
platforms you really need to make your
content from one or two platforms just
repurpose it on the ones that are
relevant
you're not going to post a funny video
on LinkedIn but anything
business-related Coast they're on
Twitter you can post anything on
Facebook post anything in the last
platform that really matters is tic toc
so tic toc became all the rage this last
year they spent couple hundred million
dollars with all a bunch of my friends
and our agencies to get them celebrities
posting it causes huge snowball was
turning to an avalanche and now it's
just I'm stoppable the reason is they're
the only platform that allows you to
share to all the other platforms and
it's connected to everything and if
anything is doing well on there
sometimes you can go crazy like my wife
made a video when she had 2,000
followers got 1.6 million views
it was just her touching a wall that was
it
and so I've got videos that are business
videos that getting 200 300 400 thousand
views on a video half a dozen times now
I don't have a large tik-tok following
but every so often it's like 3,000 views
12,000 views 8000 a quarter million
10,000 15,000 400,000 and so that can't
happen on any other platform it just
doesn't you don't have that situation
unless something goes viral on Twitter
which is once in a blue moon
so tick-tock actually allows you to go
viral if you will by just doing things
right make good content these right
hashtags yeah and do you feel like most
of these content creators are trying to
be relevant on every platform or do you
see them come picking one platform
dominating that and then maybe adding
another and kind of methodically going
through it in a sequential way or is it
just like be everywhere all the time
from day one so I recommend them all to
be omnipresent I recommend them to be on
every platform
very few are most of them are focused on
one platform and maybe two and they're
really all in on that one platform like
I love Instagram or I love YouTube
YouTube influencers literally nicknamed
a YouTube influencer they should just be
an influencer we all call them YouTube
influencers right and so same thing with
tick tock if somebody is huge on tick
tock we don't call them a social media
monster and Calma tick tock sponsor and
so because of that they're missing out
on what could happen or shouldn't happen
meaning whatever tick tock goes away or
whatever chump says you know what no
more tick tock they have this crazy
situation with China done or done with
tick tock what do you do if you're your
17 year old kid with 16 million
followers and tick tock and you'll have
a couple thousand everywhere else and so
I'm very a huge proponent okay you've
built up a big tick tock or YouTube or
whatever cross-promote get your other
platforms going you're not gonna get as
big on the other platforms but you need
to have a base because what if we don't
know you don't know if Instagram goes
away one day or Facebook goes away one
day or take tacos away one day it's
unlikely right Facebook Instagram
Zuckerberg is too young and too rich why
would it ever go away it's never gonna
get acquired but we don't know we didn't
expect our whole world to get shut down
over over this further thing so like we
don't know what can happen the world so
it's dangerous to be only on one pop one
yeah
when the vine star saw us right we're
basically vine was here that much we
built up their audiences and it
disappeared but many of them were able
to cross out and kind of go in with the
platform spilled an audience but many of
them also didn't make it right no I know
a lot of them absolutely so let's talk a
little bit about 100 million Academy and
kind of what you're doing there and also
the mastermind that you have
recently let's sort the mastermind
because I think that a lot of people I
spoke with that either went to it or
participate in it they were just blown
away by the quality of the event and and
the amount of knowledge and value that
was shared so he tell us a little bit
about what it was and kind of how you
set it up so 100 million mastermind
experience was a hundred thousand
dollars per person so it's one of the
most expensive masterminds in the world
and if I was going to create something
that expensive I had to make it like
holy [ __ ] like this is a crazy level
event but also not just from the
celebrity side but actual content in it
so I did was I signed 22 instructors
annual contracts and be the instructors
the requirement was that either do over
a hundred million revenue spend over a
hundred my own ads or been seen by over
a hundred nine people so those were the
22 instructors so it wasn't just about
me my partner as the instructors because
most masterminds it's all about the one
or to instruct the one or two founders
and everybody else is a guest so I
assigned these instructors actually have
to come the whole year my partner Joe
Merion he's going one the biggest email
list in the world 19 million person
email list seven hundred million dollar
supplement company and so I wanted him
as my partner because one the business
acumen he has but two he had that
passion and belief with people and he
likes to create these large-scale events
and so we said okay if we're gonna
charge people this huge premium a
hundred thousand dollars per person how
and why and so we went out and sought
after we're gonna make these weekend's
multi-million no we spent 2.1 million
dollars in three days for our first
opening weekend to put on a show we
brought in Mark Wahlberg Nick Cannon
Tyga Chris Tucker Kris Jenner
Magic Johnson Charles Barkley Dennis
Rodman all these characters that were
across different segments the CEO of
Sirach the owner of beautycon all
different types of characters to teach
amanda cerny right so those influencers
celebrities actors athletes all in one
weekend and in between there we had
different speakers so we had the wolf of
Wall Street Marcus lemonis from the
profit Jim quick the memory coach we had
Carl Lentz a celebrity preacher he's
like Justin Bieber's preacher and he was
one of the best features of the whole
thing so we're trying to hit every
checkmark of like hey we have a preacher
I'm Marcus lemonis from CNBC you know
the wolf of Wall Street
like you have they all different
characters so the whole weekend and so
that's where it all came from is like
we're gonna make this super high-level
in but we ought to make sure that people
paying this kind of money we have to
make sure it's overwhelming for them and
that's where the 100 million kademan
came from was well we only can have a
hundred people at these events right 100
people who sold out for it so I wanted
something that we can make for the
masses so we made a hundred bucks a
month and 100 bucks a month it's the
same 22 instructors plus we film
hundreds of hours of content with other
instructors so well unlike somebody like
pump and say hey can you come on here
when you come teach us about business
finance and explain to us and we'll film
with you for three or four hours and
we'll go get this instructor to talk
about cannabis this instructor to talk
about email marketing this instructor to
talk about social media well we brought
on all these people they'll all teach
for three or four hours each and we have
hundreds of hours of content out and
then the difference is we're actually
going live every single day of the week
with a different instructor and so
they're not just getting the hundreds of
hours of content from the past or active
content we keep updating but literally
every single day at 6 p.m. we're going
live and I'm giving away Bitcoin cash
every single night I'm like hey what's
your Bitcoin hey what's your cash up
code hey what's I'm just giving away
cash prizes every night with a different
instructor yeah and so what's the
thought process behind the types of
instructors you bring on the live versus
that you would record kind of the more
evergreen content with sure so the 22
instructors those are people that are
part of the mastermind itself the ones
that are coming on for the live or both
so all 22 of them jump on the lives but
in between they're like last night we
had the guy who owns 28 locations of a
ever bold acai chain tonight we have a
girl she has six million a year clothing
sales and she's one of the members in a
different group so we're trying to make
it different where you're gonna get all
the people that do the honey
million-plus but you're also going to
get these a guy with ten million dollars
retail chain a lady with six million
dollar clothing grant so we're trying to
get all of the above or not taking on
anybody that doesn't have at least mid
seven figures or higher revenue because
we want to make sure that it's all
people you really can like dive into and
believe and not wonder fish you should
be listening for them that's kind of our
vetting processes that we know them we
know they're doing real revenue
and they're going to be helpful to our
students yeah and all of this really I
think kind of comes down to your belief
of just like everyone needs to educate
themselves right they're not going to
get a lot of this education in school so
maybe talk a little bit about that yeah
so I think it's gonna be a human we're
gonna come back to new worlds like
colleges were already like a big thing
you'd always hear about Mark Cuban a lot
of characters we're talking about
colleges being so expensive and
unrealistic and a huge college that that
became so unreal right now a lot of
these colleges will just not reopen or I
can have much lower attendance because
parents are realizing like whoa I'm
paying 40 grand for this place but she's
been learning on zoom' every day and
just fine and maybe I don't need that
now the Ivy League's are never gonna go
away
because as parents you're gonna still
walk harbor neo on your son their
daughter's resume right however I just
believe that I want to learn from
somebody that's done it or like really
really done it and no offense the most
instructors but they haven't built a
hundred million dollar company and
there's a big difference than talking
about it and reading history books and
actually being somebody that did 148
million revenue or did 600 million
protein sales right and so I wanted both
meaning I still like the traditional
forms that you can learn from school and
I wanted to structure in a way that
somebody that did 600 million protein or
20 million email lists or honeymoon and
cannabis to teach it in a way that we
can learn easily realistically yeah and
then what type of students are you
seeing that are coming in and wanting to
learn this is this people who are
replacing college is this people kind of
out of school who actually I've started
a company what do you see there yeah so
I actually have a lot of adults a lot of
people have a business they're an
entrepreneur they own three restaurants
and they own a dry cleaner
they were accountants and lawyers and
doctors they have a lot of adults on
there I want I want college kids age and
above it's not not to say that high
school kids and young adults can't watch
it but really our content is for
somebody that's got a business or wants
to expand their business or they're an
influencer or there's somebody that
builds up a podcast they want to learn
how to expand it and some of that has
entrepreneurial wants and needs but I
say right now a lot of our members are
actually older than I expected yeah it's
super cool
and then any main takeaways that you've
seen so far it's kind of you guys have
sort of created in the content and
seeing how students are reacting from it
and anything that you've either
surprised you or it's been a main
takeaway yeah the main comments we get
is how practical it is because they're
actually using it so I'm like comments
this morning I'm sitting in the group
chat somebody said hey my email open
rate went from like whatever the number
was 4% so at 9% and just because I did
this this and this then somebody else in
the same hour said hey I had a 23%
conversion on my website I changed the
Buy Now button here just like you said
and now it's 36% for eight days in a row
and so we're seeing comments of just
real practical stuff because again the
people that are coming on teaching
they're not teaching esoteric like oh
the secret if you close your eyes and
hope you know the secret is gonna make
it come six months from now we talked
about really very practical things and
that's what I'm getting the most
response about yeah I love that what's
your advice right now for somebody who
who's usually probably a little bit
younger and they say hey I actually want
to go and become an influencer or if you
will right so they want to be successful
is what I usually hear them say what
they really mean is they want to build
an audience online and whether it's to
do advertising is to build a product or
even to one day you know be a teacher
400 million academicians like that
what's kind of your general advice for
them my main thing I like to say is keep
your day job because what happens is you
need income along the way and you're
gonna create better content if you have
money you're gonna be able to just
travel to more places do more things and
so you don't need to be rich to be an
influencer but you need to have a couple
grand a month just to like cover your
bases cover your bills make sure
everything's taken care so you're not
struggling from post to post too many
influencers when you joke about the
agency all the time
unlike the 28th of the month I get hit
up by hundreds of different influencers
like hey you have any posts for me
because the rents due in three days and
this is the same influencer I paid four
grand
eight grand fifteen grand the month
before that I know that's not their
overhead but they spent all their money
and so the main thing I'd say is having
some consistent income and having some
money saved up again doesn't have to be
a lot just that consistency will help
it'll help free your mind for your
content and what you have to really
think is if you can focus on a niche you
will stand out a beauty influencer is
far and away the number one most engaged
content most thing
agent Munster in the world it's not
close then you drop weight yeah and it
gets at Fitness simple answers they do
extremely well and then you have
everybody else but from the everybody
else is there's certain pockets like
people that focus on cars or focus on
video games I focus on certain beauty
etc those people are they're gonna crush
it because if you had 110 thousand
followers and you just talk about video
games I'm gonna get you a really good
array from a video game of mobile app
company if you're just under 10,000
influencers and you sometimes play video
games you sometimes talk about salad and
you sometimes talk about puppies I'm not
gonna get you any kind of rate it's
gonna be like couple under bucks so if
you can find a niche and really go for
it on that niche and then build up your
content on multiple platforms and find
other people in the niche that you like
so if you're in the beauty space and you
like these influencers try to replicate
some of their type of content make it
for you or the dream is go go do post
with them or learn from them yeah
why is the beauty segment so highly
engaged compared to everything else so
it's because their content starts off
with them no makeup on and they're Ross
form talking through it with them for an
hour and so because of that people as
fans we believe them when you notice if
you see a post and they're just the
perfect pretty post their engagement
it's very different when they do a post
and they're completely wrong their bags
over their eyes and they're about to do
their makeup their engagement is four
five six seven hundred percent higher
because people will leave that and so a
lot of times when you even see content
and you see Gary B and ty Lopez holding
up their phone right they're making the
content it's like this now it's because
that content from their phone doesn't
feel like they're you're selling them
something right when you see closed
captioning and titles and all these
graphics it feels like a commercial or a
movie when you see them holding up their
phone you feel like you're talking to
them and you don't feel like they're
trying to sell you so you need both you
need some content that's very raw which
is why meet Ian Fletcher's do so well
but then they show the finished product
everybody loves it so whether you're a
business influencer like Gary and you're
making this content people feel
comfortable with you during that and
then when you make yourself on stage or
you have the big
they're not scared of you because now
they feel a part of you and so I would
say if you can make your content feel
very real when I say feel very real
because Israel don't don't make it it's
it's hard to say but like so many people
try to make like the feel like they're
sad today and then overdramatic or they
say that they worked out when they
didn't really work out people people can
feel it yes it almost feels like the
authenticity is the is the great
equalizer right absolutely that's why
the Kardashians are so big because we've
seen them all
having breakups and deaths and cheating
on this happened and that happened and
this guy loved her for this and this
one's dating this one like that behind
the scenes is why the Kardashians are so
big we felt like we've grown up with
them for the last decade love them or
hate them both are valuable to them yeah
do you think that we'll see more people
kind of build their audiences off these
reality TV shows or is it straight to
social media down so what stuff is
there's just too much content available
so when we grew up the real world was
real we can name it because there wasn't
any competition now there's 50 different
shows on mainstream platforms that are
all reality based but then there's
hundreds of shows on Hulu Netflix Apple
will grow through this that you know
like just too much content to choose
from when we were growing up we didn't
have that many options they were just X
amount of shows we can name Saved by the
Bell
knew the shows that were just like in
our head in school now there's 999
channels 24/7 Plus Hulu Netflix Amazon
Apple Disney there's just so many
different things so it's just too hard
the TV side of it is really meant for
credibility getting on a Netflix show
huge credibility but on social media
you're gonna be like crush away more
eyeballs yeah the top influencers if you
need to break down their revenue what do
you think the percentage-wise
advertising versus products they sell
versus maybe it's you know television or
Netflix or something like that like how
do you think that revenue breaks down
yeah so very few of them actually on TV
movie etc so that's really rare and even
from those they're not getting paid the
rates that you
expect even though they have large
followings they are getting chosen
because of their social media following
some of the times but they're not
getting some crazy rates and there I
don't think they care which is an
interesting part of it however on the
product side if an influencer has a
large following their product revenue
will crush what they're paid post
relevance if they have a large following
because if you go sell 10,000 units of
something and it's 40 bucks that's
$40,000 revenue that's not net but
you're gonna make a hundred hundred
grand on that it's a lot of money that
same influencer is not making six
figures most of the time from their
paint posts now other influencers if
you're talking about like jake paul or
logan paul i mean they're making
millions and millions of dollars from
their paint posts but even then their
product brands are doing eight figures
compared to making seven figures for
papers so i'll always say if you can
make a product and make it scalable and
make sure you ship the product and make
like follow through like it's a real
product brand like you're an actual act
like a CEO you can make way more money
than your social paid posts yeah what's
interesting to me is most of the
products we've seen there's very few of
them that have built digital products
right many of them have actually built
physical price so it's the t-shirts it's
the makeup kids it's the you know all
the different physical products but
maybe there's like I think Sam Harris
built like a meditation app right
there's a couple of people who've built
digital products but not many yeah they
should make games because I've watched
them over and over make games number one
apps or top ten apps so many times it's
crazy like app budgets I'm getting mid
seven-figure a year in app budgets to
pay influencers but they should then
make their own apps and games themselves
and so what happens is they just don't
focus on it and so they like do a paid
post for an app or they'll do a post for
a game for me and then it does well it
gets the top ten but they don't ever I
don't know why they don't go make their
own because it's not that hard anymore
it was hard for years ago now you want
to go make a game there's all these app
companies that are like hey well just
white leg lows for you we already made
this version of flappy birds or you know
and here you go we'll call it amanda
fluffy and then all the sudden that's
their that's her thing it doesn't happen
and I don't know why yeah
yeah and I guess really once you get
past the game part of the digital
products there I don't know really what
else they can make unless they have the
niche right it's almost harder if you're
kind of more of a broad audience to
actually come up with a physical or
digital product versus like a Sam Harris
the meditation app right if you were
enough you know financial industry you
could make maybe like a financial
planning app or something like that but
the niche almost feels easier to build
the digital products than the the more
broad appeal type influencer they should
try to go get equity and I you know it's
interesting to me because the some of
these household name celebrities and big
influencers should have gone and trying
to get equity from these companies like
you look at Ashton Kutcher well he got a
little piece of air being B that's a
huge difference compared to the most
influenced or the most TV stars they
don't have piece of air being me right
where the Kardashians for example I just
use them as the easy example like if
they had equity in an air B&B that would
be worth more than their humungous
empires right would you rather have 3%
and Airbnb worth X amount of billions
then because the Kylie situation is a
rare one off right and think about how
many thousands and thousands of
celebrities and thousand thousand
influencers all have beauty brands what
she did is an anomaly right why what why
was she successful in others weren't
because she all she cared about she post
about it every freaking day every week
and she was actually at the White House
she was working with them working with
the manufacturer it's a very small team
there's only seven or eight kids there
it's not some big fancy they don't have
some huge staff it's fascinating to
watch they watched it in the very
beginning like it was and watch the
headaches from the very beginning of how
much traffic crashing their site um she
was all in and too many times people
just put their face on it no pun
intended like they just put their face
on a beauty brand and that's it and the
reason that you see like a Jeffrey star
and I mean that kid broke shopify hey
Jeffrey story is that story so Jeffrey
star he he partnered with it does a it's
like 20 million views for her YouTube
video named Shane Dawson so Jeffrey star
Shane Dawson Odd Couple if you will
Shane Dawson does like
josé's on Jake Paul and on different
influencers and like long form they take
a year to create and he makes these
documentaries it's 20 million views per
thing
Jeffrey star is this very tall very
flashy makeup artist covered and
painting on makeup
he created a beauty brand doing 70
fingers revenue well Shane Dawson
Jeffrey starter BFFs made a brand
together they launched it it's on
YouTube you guys should watch the
documentary it's pretty long but there's
a couple main episodes where you can
actually see the lodge
they broke Shopify 1 million units they
had in the warehouse thing about the
gamble it pre bought 1 million units
they did over I think was 60 or 70
million dollars in revenue in 24 hours
Wow
it's hard to like say it out loud like
the gamble the idea the concept they
like did a full national rollout with
one main chain store a beauty chain
store at the same time they did this
launch with a million units of their
kids but also they had upsells of
brushes hoodies bags etc the numbers are
staggering just look at Jeffrey star
Shane Dawson it'll blow your mind the
number it's like yeah I mean I mean yeah
this begs the question though like is
this the future of business right is it
going to be now built the audience first
then go build the product versus the
historical model of build the product of
England the audience right so I think
it's I think it's interesting as if you
can tell the story along the way people
feel more compelled and so the reason
that the Shane Geoffrey worked was they
showed the story along the way
Louisa Kylie worked was she showed her
posting but all the time picking out
posting like be like red purple or blue
do you like which color do you like and
she's like posting asking questions
people felt a part of this so by the
time they came out was it everybody
wanted it they felt like they were part
of the process watching it and so music
artists should do that more like some of
them post in the studio they should
literally be posting snippets all the
time for those whole that whole at four
months Bieber did the best as he just
kept posting snippets behind the scenes
showing him making the album and so when
it came out it breaks all these records
because people feel a part of the story
people
buy-ins of the story way more than the
thinnest products yeah I love that
before he's finish up I do some rapid
fire questions and then you could ask me
one question to end what uh what's your
favorite book
I think buck is gosh I'm gonna have an
easy one for that I actually like
thinking of rich and just like the old
school classic yeah that's a it's easily
one of the my top three what uh what's
your most controversial thought when it
comes to social media internet and
business people are sheep is that
controversial when people don't say
everything is controversial now 2019-20
like it's just as a setback like before
people issue and they believe everything
and it's scary yeah
what about aliens believe her mom
believer absolutely why I think it would
be egotistical and cocky for us not to
think that yeah that's that's fair what
one question you have for me to finish
up I didn't do it off so you know
everywhere I listen before before I met
about three four years ago I didn't
sleep at all now I actually sleep eight
hours and somehow I get more work done
so it's kind of this weird thing where
when you slow down a little bit you're a
little bit more intentional you can
actually more productive in some weird
way rather than feeling like you're
always kind of running to catch up I
don't know so far so good
alright awesome and I appreciate you
doing this and I think people will enjoy
learning from you and then everyone
hopefully will go so where can I
subscribe to a hundred million Academy
yeah honeymoon academy.com
alright thank you very much I appreciate
it thank you